good morning it's kind of a very sunny
island sky i must say very pleasant
honor oh good for you it's not here well
maybe it is i don't know i can't see
just at the moment what i do know is
that the chancellor has voluntarily
asked the prime minister to look at the
declarations that he's made he feels
that he has done nothing wrong and has
behaved within the letter of the law
well there is the problem if the
chancellor can't see that he's done
nothing wrong but he's had the status
but he's had this green card which in
effect means
that you're supposed to live in the
united states supposed to pay tax in the
united states
and this is the chancellor of the united
kingdom that's passing tax laws for the
rest of us
you know you can talk about the rules
and all the rest of it but this is a
serious lack of judgment
it's really a failure of morality and
ethics that the chancellor should have
been expressing that his future was in
the united kingdom any idea that he
would benefit from having a green card
and entitling him to live and work in
the us and my goodness kate the irony of
this that he was part of the tory
government that pushed through the
brexit deal that took away the rights
that we all had to live and work in the
european union yet this man retained the
rights to live and work in the us it's
not good enough and when you consider
everything that we're all facing over
these days the increase in tax that
ordinary people are facing the real
pressure that people were under and yet
his wife has used the non-dom status to
be able to
shelter income i have to say for the
chancellor
it's not about the rules it's about a
serious lack of judgment and on the back
of that quite frankly not only are we
looking at a man that has no future as a
potential prime minister that has gone
he ought to really consider his position
on the back of this because quite simply
he and others in the leadership of the
tourney party just don't get it when
they demonstrate there's one rule for
them and another rule for the rest of
the public that are struggling through
this 20 cost of living crisis
we don't know that he didn't pay tax in
the united states though do we and we we
do know that his wife you know was
perfectly entitled to do what she was
doing and isn't it not just a teeny
weeny bit sexist to say that she should
have to do what her husband tells her to
no of course
it's not about that but let's let's pick
our way through that we know from his
spokesperson that he paid appropriate
taxes where he was supposed to do so uh
they need to come clean on his tax
affairs and i think probably under the
circumstances it's best to clear this up
that he publishes his tax accounts
whenever they were paid as far as he's
always concerned of course we shouldn't
be talking about families in the main
but the principle here is the
ministerial code makes it clear that the
financial interests of your spouse are
included in the declarations that you
should be making and when you've got the
chancellor of the exchequer that's
putting pressure on households up and
down these islands and yet his wife is
able to declare income outside the
united kingdom not pay tax on that
should be paying about 2 million pounds
a year and my message to them today is
they should be paying that back tax and
let's not forget even with the
declarations that they're now making
that his wife will not be subject to
inheritance tax in the uk quite frankly
sunak and those that are in the
leadership of the tory party are
treating us all as fools
do you have any sympathy with him at all
suggestions that it's a bit of a
political hit job from number 10 because
he wasn't as supportive as he could have
been during partygate
it's obvious that there's been a fallout
between
the chancellor and the prime minister
there's no doubt that that is part of
all of this and
my goodness boris johnson's managed so
far to navigate himself
uh through the partygate crisis he still
needs to be held to account for that but
it's clear that those he saw these
nearest challengers are being dealt with
in a in a fairly brutal way but you know
my message is it doesn't need to be like
this when we look at the charge sheet
against boris johnson against richie
sunak we've had all the scandal of
partygate we've had the paying of
wallpaper for number 10 we've had the
crony deals that put people in the house
of lawrence we've had those that get
stuffed into
uh
ppe deals uh through fast track this is
a government that stinks to high heaven
it's about corruption it's about sleaze
this is just the latest example of it
and quite frankly the sooner they're all
gone the better
what is it with all you politicians
trying to get me in trouble this morning
lord guide said that there was not no
problem as far as the wallpaper was
concerned and the prime minister acted
uh within the rules
well come on at the end of the day the
prime minister went down and solicited
donations to refurbish as flat it's the
style of behavior and the way that what
they seem to think can get away with
rest of us in normal life quite frankly
look upon this and what they see is that
people that have a sense of entitlement
boris johnson and his elk have behaved
this way ever since they had that
privileged upbringing that eaten and
the whole lifestyle that has gone with
that and the fact that through all of
this that you've got a prime minister
that's that's presided over the culture
of partying at number 10 when everybody
else was behaving the cover drills there
was real anger
up and down these islands and it's right
that people are saying that when you
fail to live up to the standards that
the rest of us are expected to do so
quite simply you should go
i think probably one of the takeaways
from all of this for people watching at
home this morning might be that politics
is brutal
yes it is bruce okay and i think we do
need to have in many respects a gentle
type of politics but there has to be
honour and dignity and when you've got
people that cling on to office when
they're clearly in the wrong then that
sets the tone that sets the culture i
mean i want us to be able to discuss the
many serious things that are in front of
us how do we get help to people in this
cost of living crisis for example but
boris johnson and richie sunic make
themselves the story do that stop being
the case they have to remove themselves
from the field
um just before i let you go i know that
while i was away you brought um some
youngsters back from ukraine didn't you
with help of others um how are they
getting them
well they've settled well into into
scotland uh 54 orphans have come from
ukraine it was just fantastic to see
that so many people came together and
i'm so proud of everyone that made this
happen that there is a point of all this
locate is that we need to do more to
make sure that we're rescuing other
vulnerable people from ukraine and
getting them here it's taking too long
to get people to sanctuary but i'm so
delighted that these young people
are able to settle and enjoy life in
scotland for now
okay good to talk to you mr blackburn
thank you for joining us from the
beautiful isle of skye this morning
thank you